if you want to see the story uh tyler i
want to text it to you uh uh it was very
important for adam for us to show it
because everybody's asking which one do
you want me to send it to by the way vt
macbook pro okay
it's coming your way this is to danielle
and the rest of the vitamin audience i
can't get like you know i can't have
like an allergic reaction to a virtual
cat tyler try to not show any of the
private mario videos anymore it's a
little awkward but
i press play
adam's definition of a productive day
and being productive
can your dog do that
[Laughter]
he's so proud though this is the cat
catching the nerf basketball okay that's
really um
adam i think you need to get out more
danielle how many alpha male do you
think wake up playing with their cat
like that i mean that's to me it's
inspirational if you ask me there's a
market for it well it's amazing
i can tell you this much there's one
there's one market for sure there's one
person in the market no i i think how
about adam can't even get the ball to
the rim that's the problem
i've got a good i've got a good uh
hanukkah already come and gone however
for next hanukkah i was in paris and
this guy was walking around with um
he he had on a backpack yeah and the
front of the backpack was a plastic
bubble
that you the clear plastic bubbles it
was like a backpack that you wrote on
the front of your body it's kind of like
a
you carry a baby or something baby
snuggler a baby not that i ever did that
um and then inside of the bubble was a
cat
so the guy was effectively taking the
cat out for a walk just to do some
sightseeing what a sweetheart
and i'm like what the that's a
sweetheart though and i'm like
scrambling to get my phone and take a
picture cause i'm like nobody's gonna
believe this well did you hear the story
about the woman getting kicked off the
plane because she was nursing her cat on
the plane yeah that was a legit story
about a month you know what you know
what adam did adam found out her name
and he dm'd her i don't know if you know
that or not true story anyways adam we
love you we miss you is dm a technical
term is who it's t is dm
yes is that like it's not like it is a
technical term so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you